i think we all felt that way yesterday
watching as the news was coming in the
best the country has to offer and i
thought the president said it best when
he said we all feel outrage and
heartbreak heartbreak in particular
absolutely
104 000 lives pulled out of that country
and saved there were lives on the line
to do it and we saw that yesterday i
know as the news was breaking guys as
you know it always changes i kept
thinking if i was a family member
waiting to get word if you knew a loved
one was there the agonizing way to
finding out either yes or no was was
heartbreaking to watch it yeah god bless
our troops i mean every single day they
put themselves on the line to protect us
and protect our interests including
today continues let us not forget that
that's where we're going to begin with a
renewed push by u.s forces at kabul
airport to get even more people out of
afghanistan after not one but two
suicide bombings yesterday killed more
than 100 people 13 of the dead as you
know by now are american service members
including 10 marines it is the deadliest
day for u.s forces in afghanistan in a
decade the bombers struck late in the
afternoon at an airport entrance packed
with people more than 100 were wounded
an affiliate of isis has claimed
responsibility for the attacks charlie
daggett is watching the response
afghanistan is bracing for more to come
after yesterday's attacks the country
and the u.s military for that matter
remain on a state of high alert but even
while u.s forces are dealing with their
losses they remain focused on the
mission at hand to get as many people
out as they can in the days ahead
with the clock ticking this morning
evacuations are still underway desperate
people defying isis threats just to
escape
but at abby gate the scene of one of
yesterday's blasts alone taliban fighter
stands among the belongings left behind
frantic people scattered in all
directions after the explosion amid
rumors that more suicide bombers were on
the loose
images of the immediate aftermath piles
of bloodied bodies in the sewage
drainage ditch made clear that first
bombing took a devastating toll
overstretched and under-equipped medical
staff struggled to save lives many
terrified workers had fled when the
taliban took over kabul
there's been no pause to the last
evacuation planes taking off but most
european countries had already planned
to bring an end to their flights today
credible intelligence from the u.s and
its allies had seen these attacks coming
we always thought there would be a risk
that escalates as we left in general
terms isis being probably the most
ruthless uh the most uh
cowardly when it comes to its type of
attacks but also the one that doesn't
really have any regard for life was
obviously the prime suspect
isis claimed responsibility for the
bombing posting the image of an alleged
suicide bomber
this morning for some the mass
evacuation has now become a mass burial
relatives collecting the bodies of loved
ones victims to the very violence they
were so desperate to leave behind
the airport remains a vulnerable target
centcom commander general kenneth
mckenzie said intelligence revealed very
real terrorist threats including a
possible rocket attack or using a car or
truck suicide bombing
for cbs this morning charlie dagetta
doha